[Musik]
herzlich willkommen der sternstunden
religion in letzter zeit einmal ein
fertig noch an anderer stelle sofort
pfingsten und vor kurzem freundlich nahm
christliche fertig macht das nur sinn
wenn jörg vogt und zwar am tag nach
fronleichnam innere katholische garten
in einsiedeln im kanton schwyz was
viermal an fronleichnam ja das habe ich
mich an ich habe ehrlich ich weiß es ist
gut dass haben ich bin also nicht
katholisch und weiß dass das eine zu
gott gott um die toten
ich glaube sich in ein gedanke an die
verstorbene und sind die prozession als
mein guter ruf der friedhof das ist das
wo nicht
fronleichnam eine frau leicht verstehen
also himmelfahrt
also das heißt frei schwarz und
christian eigentlich die über 60 würde
ich jetzt meine und was bedeutet das
das kann ich nicht sagen es ging darum
das christliche fest
ein blut fest von jesus christus und
zwar das frönen
dieses blut festes von von jesus findet
sie als viel religiöse 40 nein nein
kritik wie nach der jüngsten
das gehört das kürzel aber so zum
beispiel zu unserer westliche religion
gar nicht wehgetan
ich finde es schade wenn die weltlichen
gesellschaft mbh ist romantik aufgemacht
luft machte sich sehr schade wenn wir
einmal bedienen kritisierte genug and
find ich super
jetzt geht es bei mir würde sagen ja
also ein 40 und weiß ist das erscheint
mir vielleicht verzichten
ich habe mal eine katholische gebiet
geschafft nur wenn ich meine kollegen
gefragt hatte warum hat jetzt schon
wieder frei die einen sagen müsste ja
sind christliche fertig es auslaufmodell
wenn glück immer wisse was führt wird
wir sichtbar sollten religion unserem
alltag überhaupt nur sie zum beispiel
mit den schützen kopf durch oder eine
kippa darüber diskutieren jetzt im
studio civil vor sich theologen und
reformierte pfarrerin im kilt bergen
kanton zürich
sie meldet sich immer wieder über zweite
aktuelle debatte zum thema religion
sie hat aus wort zum sonntag sprach
radio 2014 bis 2016
da valentin abgottspon erich
vizepräsident von der
freidenker-vereinigung vor der schweiz
und erschaffen als lehrer zweiter und
die rechtliche 40 abschaffen und durch
freitag ersetze und der alfred
bodenheimer er ist professor für
religionsgeschichte und literatur vom
judentum der universität basel und er
schrieb auch kriminalroman ja valentin
abgottspon wenn sie denn de lüt die
rechtliche 40
nein es geht ja nicht ums abschaffung
sinnvoll wagner
es geht um die vierter war etwa vertritt
nimmer wichtig ist was der hintergrund
ist also sechs etappen freundlichen
haben wir ch oder den pfingstmontag
eigentlich wäre es wahrscheinlich zieht
gemacht als man das öffnet wird also
dass man der arbeit und bevölkerung
freitag nimmt aber dass man einfach
in religiöse lauda hat also dass der
staat nimmt man seit david religions-
hintergrund war wird er sondern dass man
die free geht wie er nach duo stroh
saarland wirklich liebe meiner meinung
nach hängt das schild wachs lutz mal zu
mal wirklich erfasst also wäre natürlich
toll für mich das fast von der familie
und von der zeit miteinander verbringen
und nimmer religiös also es geht
eigentlich darum dass im biz fritz
katers lied zum beispiel vier oder fünf
vor deiner tag einfach frier kann die
sätze das hätte sogar ein vorteil
das lied war ein anderer oder keiner
religion hand aber nicht gezwungen sind
der pfingstmontag fritzlar und der
fronleichnam
ich hätte eigentlich hoffnung dass der
clip einfach da oder flexibel kannte sie
ja also so religiös sind software oft
gelacht ich hier fertig aber nicht was
sagen sie zum vorschlag von valentin
abgottspon ja also als gut 4 ich kann
die christliche fertig natürlich wir
haben sehr viel eigene fertig wofür die
rohstoffe normalerweise bedeutet dass
ihm im ferienort das durch überstunden
kompensieren das ist schon zusätzliche
belastung ich weiß halt nicht ob das
praktikabel ist oder also ich halt wie
gut dass ihm ein museum oder im prinzip
besteht und italien im garten und ist an
und für sich aber christlich fundierten
tag gut für uns ist das überhaupt nicht
in schule ganz bucht zu meinem sonstige
feile und liebe bitte vier jahre
gemeinsam dick ich würde auf eine frau
mitte 40 was heißt das für menschen
votum jüdische klar gehöre ganz konkret
wie viel ferien stehen also pro jahr
davor ab es gibt eigentlich folterszenen
mit wochenende eigentlich falls auf
ostern oder pfingsten sowie soll
entweder wir dann vielleicht in den
natürlichen glück aber es kann bis zu
sechs städte und eine abwehr moment es
drauf haben
sie sagen die musik modern alter das
wählerpotenzial nach uhr zeigt es gibt
hier sicher verschiedene stadt jährige
im judentum wird
da jetzt über religiöse und das land was
heißt das modell oder die politik nimmt
sich als maßstab für die live-shows
jüdische religionsgesetz nicht
abgeschottet sondern probiert eigentlich
sowohl im lebensstil mit allen
weltlichen angelegenheiten befasst sich
davor
ich finde es interessanter gedanke vor
der freydank aber die sind ja nicht
allein gesichert user wo dann auch sagen
wie er nach der video star soll man
junge pole ist davon konnten und genau
die unterrichtung bekannt und sie war
das diskutierte zur diskussion gestellt
hat sie mich ist es jetzt nach liegt
liste der feiertage oder also
weihnachten das camp monat das vierte
mal auch dann wenn es nötig wird
ostern mit der eier und bibel ivo so
herzig 1 kalorie der egal
das haben wir doch auch konfession
religions- übergriffen oder sogar über
ohne religiöse hintergrund 4
also die allem und zinsniveau irgendwie
nicht er sondern koste schlager hat wo
man noch in tiefer markt etwas streichen
das finde ich schwierig also dann fertig
qualifizieren über das finde ich gut man
das wieder zur debatte gestellt
ich werde aber die zum beispiel in
stellung zu bringen finde das wunderbar
es fast von der bedeutung her und meinen
auch dass das ohne explizit religiöse
hintergrund vier bars und bedeutet hat
wo wichtig ist wenn sie darüber
nachdenken ihr vorstellig vor
begeisterung für das begeistere ich mich
eigentlich im land was brandt mit her2
setze ich mich mitgliederschaft und mir
war es lieber man würde wieder bedeutung
von denen 40 räder und ich meine die
hand wirklich für die gesellschaft eine
existenzielle bedeutung was ich es lohnt
darüber nachdenken und es gab die
modelle für den freitag wenn man dann
finden das sind das entspricht
wunderbares einer individualisierten
dann zur hand aber das wird genau die
bedeutung nicht berichtigt bin wieder
fertig die wird verloren das finde ich
schon aber es wäre ja nicht dass man
nachher nur nachdem das trio fixiert
wer als nationaler feiertag zum beispiel
die recherchen oder er hätte ich jetzt
wirklich überall und noch einmal
unterschiedliche traditionen
es geht in einigen konnten ist immer ein
vier tage und ich das gefühl einfach 80
prozent von der mancha oder mehr schnitt
religion und christentum war mit dem
religiöse hintergründe dazu gehört
sondern es ist einfach ein arbeitsfreier
tag also man hat einen tag früher hat
einen donnerstagfrüh einige machen und
einblicke oder wenn es ein stück fitter
ist also im prinzip ist mir nach nizza
sehr wichtig was jetzt eine runde
für mich ist wichtig dass wir mindestens
als gesellschaft aber das um dieter fink
steht er mit mehrsprachigkeit der piste
denn das wäre will halt wirklich einem
geist vor dem fenster sah goya schweiz
hat mehrere sprachen das ist frisch
kulturelles wichtig ist dass wir ein
mehrsprachiges lagern zu das kann man
selbstverständlich um dieter was wir
aber als als modell als frieda als
humanist er wie er immer im vordergrund
dass wir jetzt nur noch zusätzliche
religiöse vier tag irgendwie
zwangsarbeit für die machen würde die
miete wer also wer vor drei zeugen nicht
dass es dann ein offizieller vierter
geht also offiziell für alle arbeitsfrei
war freidenker tag heißt oder oder eben
wie rassismus tag aber also wenn man
würde treff ist um dieter würde der wäre
ich dafür das ergebnis nehmen war für
alle passt zum beispiel an mannschafts
tag oder vorigen ist und nicht zum
beispiel halt irgendwie es für den
einzelnen
es ist natürlich jetzt sehr braven und
sehr nachvollziehbar letztlich wird
religion das habe ich denn bei gericht
stehen im dezember haben vielleicht
können sie noch kurzen auto übrigens was
frauen lieben überhaupt ist es ist dass
ich bloß um katholische kontext ich bin
reformiert mich hier kein fronleichnam
darum gebe ich das also mit der
menschwerdung ist gar nicht so falsch
und nachher geht's halt einfach
babyphone moment eine katholische
content ist eine die tradition
die monstranz nimmt der gewandelte und
also der angeblich gewandelt ich will
hier nicht so also wie kann das glaube
würde der angeblich gewandelt leib
christi dann in der monstranz werden
hofft er durchs dorf gedreht war soll
zeigen dass da wo der wiedergeborene
drittel gott also jesus präsent ist und
unter ihnen ins labor wirkt und was ich
in london hätte erzählen ja also ich wer
frieden will ich einige super religion
und religionsgeschichte weise also noch
ja sagen wenn man die bibel gehört liest
ist dass man auch enttäuscht wird aber
im wallis zum beispiel und ich stehe ist
das ziemlich wirklich so ein event also
die die prozession und darf man nicht um
zug sagen oder jemanden die
vorgeschriebenen kulturell sie schwimmt
seiner hand liegt wissen immer so genau
was abschafft verstimmte zu machen
für mich stimmt der zusammenhang nicht
wenn ich vorher versucht zu erklären
für mich ich würde davor warnen jetzt
auf grundformen zeitgeist einfacht
wirklichkeit tradition aber über
jahrhunderte sie sind einfach so
wegschmeißen oder die verträge
ausdrucksformen zeitgeist ich meinen
aber nicht dass man traditionen dorf in
frage stellen dass deutlich mehr auf
jeden fall aber ich finde den ansatz
weil für mich an anderen läden
mitglieder darüber was bedeutete dann
die fertig das wäre für mich das
ziemlich freundlich wirklicher lanze für
bedeutung von denen fertigen und ich
habe mich nicht vorher versucht seit
langem eine beschäftigt sich mit
grundlegenden existenzielle frage wofür
es alle sind machen wir es ab und zu
vielleicht auch gezwungenermaßen wieder
dem denen daten sich mit dem thema
befasst wird weil mir das wieder machen
bestimmt das für sie ich sehe das
relativ pragmatische sicht also jetzt
kaufen statt dass man sich sätze wird
für das sinnvoll deine für die ganze ist
jetzt pixel echt beängstigend sie wie
wichtig bietet wie christa
im judentum ist schon bitter so dass
normalerweise einige massa wisse was
vorbezug der 40er wo sie für ihre würde
jetzt muss auch relativ säkulare elite
xl begonnen für ihre ist eine sehr stark
mit irgendwelchen biblische ereignisse
in der regel verbunden
also kommt um zürich haben wir in der
vorbereitung pitzl kundig machen wir
vier täglich bedarf kontos sehen und der
kanton zürich schrieb zum beispiel
explizit uns historische grünen würden
halt die vierte klasse von evangelischer
christen hatten sie für den kanton
zürich
ich finde dass ich nur ganz
nachvollziehbaren das religiöse verhallt
einigen klick weil das wirklich viele
leute nicht mit bedingter hätte aber
sagen wir haben sozusagen historisch
gewachsene kultur und daher blieb
irgendwie traurig aber das bringt das
neue interessante nass aber ich zeige
sich die jüdisch rechtlich kultur oder
es gibt kein jüdische fertig wo für alle
jetzt gilt betonte er dass zum beispiel
das betrifft vor allem die hier frei
können wenn ich immer froh wenn er durch
die wichtigste und viel viel mehr
und ich habe das militär hatte ihn
natürlich gespürt ich auch immer betont
die panzer kriegt wenn andere halt im
dienst bleiben aber meter benötigt wurde
wenn die andere großfähren es aber gegen
wen ihr fach und oder löschen
ich weiß ich spüre ich wieder so also
wenn man innerem kleine minderheit auf
vox.de nicht dass nicht das was man
empfindet dann weiß man einfach da wird
jetzt wieder nach der viertorestadt
viert und mir haben einfach unser fest
und das lässt sich eigentlich gut mit
einem jahr also man muss sich das so
vorstellen wieder für so sozialisiert
wird das halt mehrheit
festakt oder festival vom kalender halt
vorgesehen und er selber vierten anders
wenn ich meine spende privilegierte
situation dass ich an der universität im
prinzip relativ einfach da sage ich
nicht weil ich dann einfach vierte konto
damit ist sagt ich mir extra ferien das
kompensieren und so weiter das ist dass
wir großes privileg ich kein lied wo
überstunden machen es ganze ort wurden
bis das was ich dir tag frei
[Musik]
das ist natürlich aus dem handy immer
noch mehr als hälfte mitglied von
landesrätin von der schweizer
bevölkerung wenn man freiwillig dazu
dass danone wo sich irgendwo im
christlichen kontext beheimatet fühlen
also es ist nicht so dass mir religiöse
gesellschaft haben und jetzt einfach nur
die die vierte kann wo kann man mit
bezug zu haben oder dass es so ist es
definitiv nicht
es zeichnet übrigens auch immer wieder
umfragen dass er stunden comics jetzt
aber will das widerrufs vor der user im
kanton zürich wurden verschiedenste
tagessieger umfrage online umfrage
machten während dieser stunden über die
kirchliche fertig abschaffen der schuss
hören und selbst politiker sagen ich bin
zwar zu vielen musste dann aber mir sind
die 40 nach wie vor liegt also darin
euro für europäische länder die schweiz
spitze ritter für physik prozent fühlen
sich als richtig und grüßte sie hat bis
über sechs prozent offiziellen
konfession steward 25% konfessionsfreie
also die konfessionsfreie widerstände je
nachdem sind der pflicht einer kraft und
will die nieten der landeskirche sind
das ist also wir sie sicher die am
stärksten wachsende bevölkerung
verlieren 2000 mit genau das sind aber
er ist da wo das wirklich wichtig ist
die wehr setzt und als aber zum beispiel
gago steuerpflicht oder oder dass ein
firmware steht soll
ich kann nur sagen also ich
selbstverständlich weil man so eine
umfrage gemacht um und hohe zahl aller
visa aber was bedeutet das aber heute
noch wenn es wäre so seid ja ich fühle
mich ein bisschen struktur verbunden
also gibt gern ja in der einer für jene
leben wir sieht verbringen mit mit der
familie nicht alle also ihre hätte er
selbstverständlich also maske also die
gottesdienste sind ja nicht einfach aber
es gibt halt kulturelle phänomen war
wirklich es war andere deren zum
beispiel auch vom november war wer die
katholik also nicht wie er sondern
einfach die katholische konzern für
ihren tod zum beispiel allerheiligen
allerseelen jetzt sich so ist er uhr
sorgt das halloween übergeschwappt und
deckschicht jugend irgendwie anders
orientieren interpretiert also von aaron
ist für mich ist das zeichen dass die
klassische institutionalisierte religion
also mit tics hoheit verloren und das
ist ein eps von hip hop mode android und
das macht einfach klick ich kann nur das
gefühl als wäre relativ schnell wenn man
da seid lasst das ist immer alles
zeitgemäß und man solle nicht alles über
die hypo tirol soll über die sache
einigermaßen bescheid wisse also ich bin
nicht dafür dass man nicht über religion
weiß will da ich kulturell einfach ein
analphabet gewisse bietet kann ich nicht
verstehen
die architektur kann ich nicht verstehen
wenn ich meine hände und mieter also das
wäre falsch schreiben als wir ist
dagegen ein anderer spieler das wird
total andere andere ziele heimische
gesellschaft aber ich denke das ist der
auftrag zum beispiel bei mir als kind
immer wachsam
sluma die gesellschaftliche
entwicklungen schnell und in sprache
notruf reagiert und ich behaupte jetzt
mit der reformierte viele machen
ich habe übrigens auch jetzt ganz aus
dem förmlichen alltag ein sehr großer
rückschritt zur tradition also das haben
wir zum beispiel unterricht werden zum
beispiel bitte bitte berlin sich das
interesse an der tradition ja wohl also
es ist und man wieder viel mehr als noch
vor 20 jahren heiraten im visier hatte
der vater führte sie einen einbruch wo
ich jetzt aus gewissensgründen muirhead
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen führt brut
innen oder übergibt sie brüten am 25
der dir die ganz traditionelle
vorstellung die sind wieder sehr gefragt
also darum es geht so nicht nur den
ganzen weg vor der tradition sondern es
gibt auch wieder rückkehr zur tradition
wo man da irgendwann halt findet wo mein
auto ist wieder von in frage stehe die
frage woher kommt das gibt es das
defizit kommen oder dass das bedürfnis
wieder da ist also ich danke mir als
relevant da duftet mit ganz ganz wachen
augen etwas leben und gesellschaft und
zur disposition für mich nicht zwei
sachen sind mir wichtig zuerst mit chris
elliott sei und immer wieder leute sind
doch frieden krems und ok-chef also muss
sich bewusst sieht dass ich nicht der
bischof war der arbeitgeber entlöhnt
dafür dass ich am samstag und am sonntag
fliegen sondern das ist entstanden durch
psychologie dass man rhythmus hat und
dass man bei ferien
das hat man sich es tritt also das ist
meine arbeitskraft war möglich dass ich
kaká und nachher der rhythmus vor 52
hätte ich also doch serbe war das modell
samstag grundsätzlich also klar
reichholf lebensmittelgeschäften dorf
und einem sonntag verstorbene besser
entlöhnt also im spital in das haus
also ich will eigentlich nicht an total
schwierig von sonntag das war also
inwieweit ein für sie nannte die amazon
hat für das hieße ja ja aber es ist also
ich will nie den sonntag war sich als
als hintergrund hat wird der
gottesdienst sondern der sonntag habe
sie ihm einfach zeit dass ich jetzt die
zeit für mich oder das geht einen
rhythmus oder das ist ja das allgemein
man schlecht ich wollte das einfach
nicht religiös verstanden habe was ich
allgemein menschlich einfach bewahrt
wurde
also einfach total die die jahrestag
durchs nummer jahres bis 385 das war
sinn macht oder vergibt und wenn wir bei
der diskussion sie wo wir her der ist
sicher wichtig dass wir nicht vergessen
das aktuell zur stand verwertet wird ein
gewisser sogenannte religiöser feiertag
zum beispiel stunts hofer straße 18
turniere organisieren und zur sache also
das sind wirklich sache war nicht da hin
zu gehört meist religiöse ihre mir also
warum darf
eigentlich beim aktuell lux am
pfingstmontag nicht durch durch str
da sind aber sofort verwendet wie es zu
dem ich mir schließlich habe ich zum
mini religiöse bedürfnis nicht im
fußball aber ich weiß es nicht ganz so
ich finde das ganze bot das hat durchaus
seine berechtigung dann wenn man sagt
man ihm die ruhetag ernst ich bin zum
beispiel auch lange völlig geöffnet
das verlautete dass man einfach sagt ja
wohl alles und ich kann alles so oft wie
es wie sollte jeder gut lustig ist oder
wie es komisch lohnt ich bin der meinung
wir brauchen ruhe tag als heilsarmee
unterbrechung vom alltag und ich finde
das wichtig finden auch ich habe mich
erinnere am kräftigen konnte und syriens
links 77 kino zurück sie man hat durch
sogar noch seine musik laut verladen so
und das hat mich alles noch dank
verbrachten die kommunale familie wo
irgendwie religionen groß glaubt worden
wäre heißt es explizit aber es hat mich
ist dank verbraucht nun das muss ein
besonderer tag sie warum warum die ruhe
und das hat für mich aber gewisse
faszination auf mich gewisse faszination
ausgeübt und das finde ich gut das finde
ich richtig finde mich braucht es muss
nicht jeden tag halligalli sie und
gottfried ich wo einfach dass die
konzentration einmal aufs liedes linien
in der realität ist tagtäglich und zwar
menschlich verschuldete lieder die das
steht für mich der konflikt oder manche
wo ob er wirklich so eines leader inter
und ihnen stürzen
und da man darüber nachdenkt und sie
hofft dass ina und einmal ganz bewusst
sagen heute ist kein tag wo jetzt
einfach friede freude eierkuchen und
alle diskus mit offen sie da bin ich
absolut dafür dass täglich ja die
verschiedenen einige wo sie die
gesellschaft gibt meine bücher
straßenverkauf alle wissen was denn das
einfach ganz verschiedenem einiger und
zugegangen was das heißt konkret wird
fertig werden müsse muss man sich
vielleicht überlegen auch andere
viertürer also dass muslimische jüdische
ein gewitter entwickeln
und grundsätzlich das müsste man
vielleicht wäre das völlig der
staatsreligion
ich weiß nicht aber das ist er nicht
also vielleicht ist dass hier politische
frage vor allem mit man das wetter
machen oder nicht dann ist natürlich
alles ganz anders mag aber mir gehört
natürlich immer nur zu berichten
ja danke frau und zieht einen vergleich
private jeder der hier sind groß so der
ramadan zum beispiel unter schwierigen
umfeld und seiner freude über die dann
sei aber in der 40
wieder genauso wie dem strich gut
ausfiel und stadtrand sind bei mir ist
mit konsequenter visa die firma oder mit
ihre ghani oder und ein siebenmeter
natürlich ja das ist so wir haben das
jugendfest und es wird abgesegnet vor
der reformierte und von der katholischen
kirche als startschuss und bekommen sich
frage darf man das überhaupt so wie
methode frage stelle ich das noch
gerechtfertigt es ganz kalt
ich glaube mit der sondern kulturpreis
minister groß dürfte der eigentliche neu
entwickelt die aus ihrem eigenen
kulturkreis sie natürlich darf es auch
mit initiation also
ich war ein guter zeitpunkt mit renault
rief ihr ticket kreieren neue vierte
karriere
es ist gut wie sich also bliebe also ich
würde vielleicht noch mal witzigen
sprüchen über die frei wählbare tag
locker tagen entwickelt jetzt bitteren
idee vor der frage eigentlich heißt das
dass man fest die android nimmt das ist
ja die user idee im prinzip aus seiner
profis macht aber der menschenrechts tag
der frau und andere oder ob jeder immer
also was sich seither vom kritik das
haben jetzt sehr stark und wird gespielt
durch jom kippur als oder oberirdische
vierte gleichzeitig erfasst da geschehen
israel said
das hat einfach kein auto auf der straße
und die säkulare das ist so fahren denn
was die religiöse jetzt nicht wird das
einmalige atmosphäre sowohl erkennen
können eigentlich nur weil es mal ab
dass wieder werden das ist also eine de
kann man sich nicht vorstellen wenn es
nicht der konsens geht
gesellschaftlicher dass man sich der tag
will als gesellschaft gar das halte ich
schon außerordentlich wertvoll und
ertragen
für jugendliche und kinder extrem tragen
und da muss man sich glaube wenn man bis
wird die villa überhaupt anderen oder
machen muss man sich sehr genau
überlegen wie man das macht was ich
denke dass jeder einfach denn die joker
tarkett oder nimmt und im prinzip hat
man einfach immer noch alltag werfen
gesellschaft nicht gut ich glaube das
heißt jetzt ist ein zusätzlicher fertig
der spieler auf der straße in europa
wollte mich fertig ist ist das untere
ruhe wo man sich gibt ja wohl irgendein
grund hat wo auf merck stimmte konsens
den halt berührt pflicht ich sehr
verordnete konsens aber erfuhren der
konsens war dass der tag der frau war
zum beispiel ja und ich hab da muss man
sich sehr genau überlegen was man rührt
was man in der gesellschaft über
sozusagen dorthin werk dort für andere
wenn man seitige werk nimmt und durch
was wird ersetzt und mit was mit der
menschenwürde
ich glaube dass es jetzt wichtigere
bedeutung hat für sie als das was die
aufgaben der bis auf ca womit mitra
mindestens für die gesellschaft so
bedeutende in holz mit mini zu
bedienender inhalt gefüllt wird weil ich
ein großer verlust wenn also in neue
sphären der vierter bin ich einfach um
jetzt kräftig oder ich wollte wirklich
nicht dass zusätzliche vierte
obligatorisch waren die obligatorische
arbeitsfrei wahren religion findet und
das fand ich einfach nicht zeitgemäß
einfach wirklich der überzeugung dass
geschichte start möglich die religion
soll bruce halte und wem werden wir den
tag der frau zum zum feiertag machen
zumal offiziell arbeitslos
kannte man das modell hat als wenn jetzt
der hofer samstag fällt oder sonntag
dass man den tag einfach nur so ein bein
qualität macht das gibt es in anderer
länder also die modell dass man sagt
okay
daher blicke ich weiß nicht ob die
katholiken der von der drv mit 4 o will
die katholische kirche hat ja das mit
der frau annika zu ganz ganz durch
durchgeführt also ich fände es gebe gute
möglichkeit aber mancherorts tag oder
tag der pressefreiheit oder irgend sowas
auch aber ich plädiere und normal
eigentlich dafür zusätzliche bisher
wirklich tritt schrieb ich bin der
meinung wäre hätten wir jetzt schon also
familie steuer bis interessant aber wo
drehen sie den euro ländern
jungsozialisten vom kanton zu jerusalem
muslime sind jetzt inzwischen ungefähr
fünf prozent von der wohnbevölkerung aus
israel bis vor dem hessischen
diskussionsatmosphäre ich nehme aber in
den bevölkerungen sehr starke abwehr
halt ich war also wenn ein vortrag vom
islam kommt ist sind die schotten dicht
vor der höfe und auf twitter ist cargo
teil der wildauer hyper nazi das finde
ich ein bisschen komische situation das
hat verschiedene gründe aber das ist
teil wie es einfach politisch ich fand
es schlauer
wenn die schweizer gesellschaft zeit
also dass das religiöse spielzeugladen
oder der friedhof werden schweiz und zu
mal großer teil davon
das lied
grundsatz religion immer so an stimmen
und wären wir sehr vorsichtig sie das
mit der religion oft mal vom staat und
von der ganzen diskussion aufs mal
wieder den wald geht was für ganze höfen
personen können wir generell
grundsatzdiskussion 30 kilo und start
letztlich oder die jungsozialisten also
das kehlener die seite von pfarrer
sieber sinne sozialwerk bis zu der
arbeit integrationsprogramm vor der
heilsarmee staatliche aufgabe über eine
religiöse also staatliche aufgabe
übernehmen als religiöse organisationen
des siegens problematisch und sie würden
letztlich schafik vor der viele stören
ja also das kommt ja immer wieder ich
heute zum verhältnis von staat nur apps
aus dem kanton zürich sage das ist
kantonal geregelt und ich weiß zum
beispiel viel zu wenig wie das sind die
regeln noch starks verhalten ich rede
von artikeln komisch interessant kurz
kühles bier und in zürich ist ja so dass
es die bestrebungen zur abschaffung vor
der viele stühle für juristische
personen gehört wohl weniger jahre hat
damals sind die jungfreisinnigen wo der
möglichen initiative richtig schwierig
wie vor richtig genau genau zuhören
abgelehnt worden also bis über 70
prozent druckseiten und das hängt damit
zusammen dass man schon
gesamtgesellschaftlich relevante wert
von der kirchlichen arbeit danach hat
also die abschaffung gefordert ist das
müssen wir einfach einmal nur eröffnen
oder will was für eine arbeit leistet
für gesellschaften zwar die
freiwilligenarbeit wo die hand das wäre
ich sehr sehr gut wenn man das müsste im
status lagere
und das ist schon erkannt worden
initiativen auch schon in der finance
klinik vielen und stadt über 60 prozent
abgelehnt wurde
also ich danke ihnen konnten haben wir
wirklich erfolgsmodell bestehen und
statuen und bezogen sind sich einig
rechenschaftspflichtig sind viele wissen
zum beispiel dass man die juristische
viele stören nun also kredite für
juristische personen nur dafür nicht
kultische zwecke verwenden mit der ftr
damit kein gottesdienst viren oder so
sondern eben nur für die sogenannte
diakonische also soziale arbeit und da
leistet diese wichtige arbeit für die
gesamt genau ähnliches modell
anton g training fehler und staat und
eine kooperation so bekannt und services
für sie als sie über die gemeinschafts
gibt's ja einzelne wo die ligna kliniken
sowie spielerische seite fall wo also
einzelne jüdische gemeinschaft eine
ganze zimmer umfang von der gemeinschaft
aber gleich anrufen also öffentlich
anerkannt sind wie ich es politisch
gemeint ist es wichtig dass viele gründe
oder dass sie im prinzip sich an die
kantonale stören können auch ein weil
früheren interview die gemeinde im
prinzip nicht kontrollieren können wer
wie viel höhere mitgliederzahl und das
ist meinte bucher die stücke der
infrastruktur zu erhalten
das ist eigentlich durch alle wichtig
die ganze es gibt vor allem orthodoxe
gemeinde aber nicht unbedingt waren teil
einer kennt sie aus kircher weil sie zum
beispiel in geschlechterfragen regel
werden haben dann nehmen wir doch kaum
erkennt werde wenn sie staatliche wo sie
nicht könnte vier aber mit einer
stattlichen erkenntnis oder gibt es auch
druck sich meint da muss ich wohl
absichtlich so kalt optisches mehr oder
weniger in jedem kanton wo seine
jüdische gemeinschaft gibt und der
etablierte jüdische gemeinde ist die
gleichberechtigung hütte folgt also ich
finde sich speziell die ich bin ganz
froh vor nicht der meinung dass gab bei
der abstimmung im kanton zürich
doch einige wissend dass es genau um die
kirche steht firma guide und das bewusst
wurde ist das detail von galt aber in
app ist altmodisch und miss modell ist
ein hacker hat sich zu organisieren
werden frei also soll es gehört für das
stadt soll ein granit diskriminierung
soulja boy nicht privilegiert und das
heißt soll eigentlich nicht mitglieder
betrage sammeln also die kirche steht
aber wirklich sind für predigt für den
qultus wirklich für religiöse sachen das
für mich nichts gemacht was aber dann
möglichkeit ist und was gemacht werden
soll ist wenn eine kirchengemeinschaft
eppishausen war für die
gesamtgesellschaft wichtig ist das heißt
in der betreuung von asylsuchenden
einfach allgemein in wichtige sache
der soll das opera leistungsvertrag
macht war da im moment teilnahme riesige
black box und dafür ist staatliches
country und erst kürzlich geriet vor
genf und somit letzte spiel vor zürich
im wallis geht und marco stier also die
zahlt das einfach und natürlich als
formular bilek oder stier erklärlich
dass die anteile von einem zug wird in
bar und in wort wird von meiner spieler
waren der erste lohn bezahlt 70
millionen zum beispiel im kanton bern
also bei einer war ist durch unser chef
hat soll das aber lässt man lieber und
training für hiller und stadt und das
modelle krippe innerhalb der das so
schlimm wird grillen also was das
ökonomisch für bedürftige kinder ja das
war schlimm
es wird aber wieder was es denn für die
stadt bedeutet also das muss man
wirklich oder eine wand all diese
tätigkeiten jetzt macht vom staat
übernommen werden
so waren es aber blickt bricht auf die
kommunale ebene dann sagen sie schildert
mit stühlen auf und war mit mit
politischen stören und das ist die
islamische gemeinschaft der hand die
diskussion ist auch intensiv als ich an
der grenze anerkennt
diese gemeinsamkeit zugang zu später los
gegangen ist und so wie das sind also
auf topniveau so dass weniger praktisch
also ich finde es braucht unbedingt
seelsorgerinnen und seelsorger vor
anderen religionen also ist ob die
vorrichtung institutionen unbedingt das
aber wirklich damit soll die kooperation
gott david übers geld und nutzen der
blackbox woche wurde ich ging noch mal
auf dem konto und ziehe ich sie
behaupten blackbox niemand ganz genau
belegt
so gab er mir das geld aus und
dementsprechend auch werde dann die gal
dritter gesprochen also das ist sehr
transparent und das ich öffentliche
panik von einer religionsgemeinschaft
hat immer mit rechten und pflichten wie
sie kontrollen sie haben es vor
angesprochen es gibt auch
religionsgemeinschaften wo sich zum
beispiel hat eine kontrolle warnt
entziehen das kann unter umständen
gewisse muslimische gemeinschaften
wirklich taktik oder ganz klar die
absicht dahinter sie nicht in das modell
zur wirklich sehr
beide seiten ich finde es übrigens auch
wichtig dass kinder gegenüber dem staat
als gewisses waldrand an wo sie immer
wieder mal worden dass kommen die
bekamen die jüngste geschichte bekennen
die fehler werden im nationalsozialismus
fürbitte gebäude der ddr widerstand
geleistet hat klage der stadt
druckseiten dass gott nicht ist nicht
mit dem evangelium in übereinstimmung
bringen da wäre - und das wachstum finde
ich ganz ganz wichtig dass kinder das
hat gibt es die diskussion wie die
jüdische gemeinschaft habe einst ende
sind dann erkannt aber viele ethische
mannschaft am primärmarkt nicht kämpft
lang ist sie da sind der 70er jahre
zuerst der kantone basel-stadt co und
der relativ viel sport durch andere
container seien zuerst unternimmt square
oder so und das ist auch der wunsch von
der eu das ist glaube es ist eine
technologische verfahren hat gegangen in
der ganzen geschichte das natürlich
jetzt praktische folge hat dass seine
form ist von hartz iv volland foto
emanzipation dass ich mal in der nahen
erkennt werde und den damen sind gilt
das holz gelungenes modell also piloten
wird werdet ihr froh jetzt nicht
diskutieren meinte vor allem eine salbe
am leben zu erhalten und ihre
infrastruktur die gemeinde sind zum teil
relativ gleich gerade zum beispiel
sportsline gemeint wo immens
geschrumpftes internet steuerbar und ihn
eigentlich mit immer weniger mittel
immer noch ordentliche infrastruktur
aufrecht erhalten wenn sie in frage
natürlich was passiert mit einer störe
wäre es doch meint austritt ist faktisch
nehmen als mutig schreiben natürlich
denn im kanton also das sind ganz viele
vogel was ich natürlich meine stelle
ganz andere konstellation als bitte
große kirche sozusagen sozial noch mal
ganz andere rolle spiele aber spannendes
gehöre man gern als anderes thema
sprechen das sind wirkt die religiöse
symbole in der öffentlichkeit aber
diskussion jetzt also eine schrittfolge
gehört und da gibt es einen entscheid
aus bayern wo die letzten jetzt
seit wochen nicht der bayerische
ministerpräsident markus söder hat es
durchgeboxt ab sofort ist in jeder
bayerischen amtsstube ein kreuz
anzubringen gegner monieren dass dieser
erlass verfassungswidrig sei doch super
verteidigt sein vorgehen aber geht es
nicht nur dass das kreuz ein religiöses
symbol ist es natürlich auch aber es ist
auch ein symbol der kulturgeschichte und
ein bekenntnis zur eigenen identität
reaktionen kamen postwendend auch im
bayerischen landtag fehlen sie heftig
aus dort die das kreuz für die hoffnung
auf erlösung bei ihnen steht das kreuz
für die hoffnung auf mehrheiten so das
was markus söder in bayern getan hat sie
ich erstmal für populistisch an bayern
ist natürlich ein sehr konservativ
christliches land ich denke nicht
bezogen auf deutschland dass wir es
überall in deutschland in dieser art und
weise ja durchführen sollten wir sind
zwar alle sehr christlich geprägt aber
das was er getan hat ist in meinen augen
sehr populistisch gewesen erst mal doch
sie mit bayern lösten im juli 2000
dennoch erhitzen sich auch bei uns die
gemüter wenn es um das kreuz im
öffentlichen raum geht beliebter
zankapfel
die gipfelkreuze in den bergen
gipfelkreuz muss man wahrscheinlich dass
kritiker übertrieb leads für babys das
dank raid sich weniger wichtige rolle
gespielt hat oder nicht
das würde würde das wahrscheinlich gar
nicht so viel lüth störe ich glaube
bislang etwa keine jugend weshalb das
gewicht der begeisterte segler und wieso
das macht
dann ist das gut für mich behalten wir
und landschaft für andere in dem bereich
die aber nur eines stört in unserer
multikulturellen gesellschaft für das
immer schwieriger den umgang mit
religiösen symbolen an öffentlichen
orten zu definieren
die baselstädtischen gerichte wagen eine
vorwärtsstrategie und verbieten ihren
angestellten generell das tragen von
religiösen symbolen der zuständigen
gerichts vorstand begründet das so es
besteht ein anspruch von menschen waren
es gericht lange für religiös neutral
skript und darum meine mir dass alle
mitglieder doch dem ausspruch insofern
dass kein druck entsteht kein entsteht
das ipad die religiöse neutralität vom
einzelnen rechts mitglied nicht gewahrt
wird das verbot vor religiöses symbol im
kanton basel stadt wie beurteilen sie
die entscheide also sehr fragwürdig muss
man sich für mich kunst hofer was im
kopf drinnen ist nicht auszuführen
hauptamtliche kraft bedenklich oder ja
und ich unterricht sieht immer an
schweizer universitäten mit mit der ig
bau über 20 jahre
was bleibt mir ein thema dass das
irgendwie es wird die neutralität
verbund gegenüber dann wohl nicht
unterricht ich habe viel glück erlebt wo
absolut neutral daher kurse voll
ideologisiert gewinne irgendwas
also ich kommt davon wenn ich vor
gericht stand irgendwo oder die
gelegenheit firma kantonale kriegt dass
die person wurde tot ist das gute niveau
vom gericht eingestellt sind also nicht
um arbeit und verdiene oder richter dass
die eigentlich offen niveau sinn und so
vom status quo alt oder sind das macht
hoffnung dass durch rechtsspruch alle
aussprüche direkt und wenn die person
irgendwo bis auf dem kopf hat amerika
dagegen nicht und dann ist es nie um
religion dänische sekunden dreams sage
aber doch sehr eindeutig ist und
plötzlich
ich glaube nur dort religion in den ort
vor sonderstellung der musik steckt
kriterium auswahl wo im prinzip
vollkommen subjektiv ist gegenüber
andere kriterien sie haben das führt zu
abgang bienen schulze moto wo sie neue
wallis unterrichtet hat sie sind
letztlich den gestörten
vertrauensverhältnis fristlos entlassen
aber die geschichte hat sich wichtige
rolle spielt sich geweigert das gesetz
immer wieder ruft also ihr eine rune
tritt zweck die andere hanke group in
bayern und bin also bayerisch hat so ein
bis zwei deutschland das ist so
da wird jetzt politik macht mit einer
symbol also dass ich ein symbol politik
und das meine ich im negativ gesehen
also das ist populismus der wilgersdorf
gehe nicht immer so und so viel prozent
und hunde und zeit ja das ist symbol
frische wasser und für ist christliche
abendland und was immer und das finde
ich wirklich negative richtig also für
mich ist es fritz und explizit als
kruzifix das dauernd jesus als
katholisches symbol und es wird mehr
zugestanden dass ich dadurch nicht die
gleichberechtigung von mann und frau
entschuldigung also dass ich einfach nie
das symbol war das für mich bedeutet
sondern es bietet verfolgung
andersgläubiger nicht gläubiger mit
gleichberechtigung von frau und so
symbol hat die schürze mit nichts hören
und nachher von dauer war der position
nicht dass der bürger und die bürgerin
als schiller als als junge mannschaft
von religiös möglichst neutrale will der
gm tochter wieder also an der
universidad sind nach einer wachsenden
lied und deutsches wort schimmlig show
weniger und immer immer am 2 romonta
erwachsene personen aber da finde ich es
schön wenn zum beispiel während der uni
fribourg überall kurze fixen und das
ganz lustig ja ich meine kantonsgericht
waadt jamina fahrverhalten verwaltung
die hand natürlich wäre der vorwand
gedrungen vor dem vertrauens verhalten
ist aber entschuldigung dass ich alle
klar worum es gegangen ist und die
verhandelt aus immerhin war einfach
kruzifixe und also das ist schon witzig
sind sie träger des rücktritts also ich
werde deine diskussion einfach dran ist
gebäude und personen oder ich bin
absoluter meine ich das schulgebäude ins
gerichtsgebäude drei religiöse symbol
gehöre dass handelt sich zum beispiel im
spital aufgenommen andachten oder dass
ich wieder besonders aber der person hat
sagt auf religionsfreiheit hat sagte er
die religion schlappe und zwar die der
öffentlichkeit
und da kürzt religiöse symbol dazu es
ist augenwischerei
nun will übers kopf durchs fritz krippe
abzüge herceptin person nur dann
plötzlich religiös neutral
selbstverständlich hinter uns steht sich
sehr ab oder heimat sich seiten
es ist extreme sich im herz bringen das
kann man nicht einfach abstellen und
dann mit dem ableger vor dem religiöses
symbol ist das nicht weg und was sagen
sie zum vorwurf dass der ausdruck von
der gewalt geschäft und frische dass das
war schön ich habe so das gefühl dass
ich finde das ganz spannend oder wenn
man über religiöses symbol retter nicht
immer gerade aber große emotionalität
das spürt man das spielt morgen gibt
verriet uns heute will jeder
konfrontiert ist mit seiner haltung zu
dem symbol oder durchsetzte wie ihnen
harry potter große verletzung passiert
vor der katholische fehlen oder es
unrecht von der politik oder was sie vor
der katholischen erfahren haben dass
heißt das ist natürlich keine sofort so
kommentiert für mich ausdruck davon dass
man sich erinnert dass besitzer von der
schwachen start dass man sich erinnert
was manchen führen impact of summer von
anderer mannschaften wurde erinnert was
eigentlich wirklich machtverhältnisse
die äußere welt wort inklusion erinnert
wo selbstverständlich auch die ebene
gott mensch manchmal erinnert das ist
für mich das symbol symbolhafter das
horizont tod von jesus erinnert daran
erinnert dass es hoffnung auf ein
bisschen berührt oder gar all das half
mir die tränen
was es für mich ein ethisches
machtpolitik aus diese basiert der
relation nicht katholisch bleiben im
jahr
interview seite irgendwann wurde der
glaube böse ausgedrückt eine beleidigung
für meine intelligenz oder es geht ja
ganz verschiedene österreichischer oder
das geht
harmlos ist glaubt die religion war aber
ich sage sie attraktiv so harmlos ist
war sehr gehört für die war ich mit der
mannschaft aber wenn es in richtig
fundamentalismus guide oder und dabei
die man nicht als manche respektiert
wird will er das oder das geschlecht
oder will kloiber hat oder andere
gläubiger hat der anders für mich da ist
für mich tatsächlich eine beleidigung
für missempfindungen was zu 80 stimmen
und war davon schweiz sind also dass das
ist ja das war nicht wirklich darf
empfindet höher
und wer vor dem jetzt diskutiert von
einer verschiedener konnten wodurch
natürlich jetzt ruhe und sage er warnt
das sehr positive beispiele zum beispiel
im widerstand vom nationalsozialismus
der deutsche hotel gab also katholische
und evangelische kirche mitgemacht hat
und voll mitmachen im anna system und
ähnlich geht es der schweiz ganz
verschiedene systeme und was du in
gewisser kleiner der verkäufer und
marshall abo oder den gewissen konnten
wir das system ist das ist nicht in
ordnung oder und auch jetzt konnten da
ich das sind das kleinigkeiten und sieht
das nicht sache waren wir total im
ersten kampf aber das symbol mit mehr
zugestanden erwartet dass es aber
umstritten ist oder
und für mich bedeutet das jetzt hat
einfache sachen war für mich nicht sehr
appetitlich sind also aber gott werden
wenn da wenn das zusammen mit der
politik und auch er probiert motor ist
grant so wie man sich nur vorstellen und
zwar neben grundschüler religion oder
eine andere religion setzte stahls
schiller und der stoff auf eine andere
religion wäre hätte ein riesiger
aufschrei werden plötzlich aber
muslimische zeichen da wäre noch
politischer art und ich finde es nicht
ganz
unrelevant oder irrelevant wäre ja auch
nicht dass zum beispiel trichter hund
und ein svp
ich finde das korrekt dass firma
repräsentant vom staat ein gewisse
zurückhaltung war da aber ich will nicht
an uniform also schüler uniform und
erleben wir es nicht nur in uniform
tragen also es gibt ganze aber nicht aus
not aufs auge
es geht was die grenze von persönlicher
ausdruck in staatlich rolle also ich bin
nicht sicher ob ihre akzeptieren würde
wenn jetzt halt ein polizeibeamter oder
eine polizeibeamtin seit ich will ein
burka tragen also wirklich ohne alkohol
also wahrscheinlich muss man das waren
reality check machen sagt da da geht es
war schönes war grenzschicht auf kleider
im öffentlichen dienst
also ich würde mal kurz was sie sagen
dass religion natürlich auch unter druck
entwickelt und liegt auch kinder diese
freiheit habe der fall im kanton basel
stadt hat sich eigentlich entschiedene
praktikantin wo hätte ins gericht und
sich mit dem kopf durch beworben hat und
eine bewusste unter die wir das will hh
unternehmens geschlossen
für mich bedeutet das im prinzip in
letzter konsequenz dass mehr
hochqualifizierte lüth wo sich waren
voll integrieren und teil vom staat war
im prinzip genau verdammte ausschließen
das wird im prinzip genau da wo im
prinzip probiere miteinander vereinbare
religiöse identitäten rede jetzt nicht
von buch das gericht muss er vom richter
oder würde ich sagen das hat mir aber
nichts beamten in deinem fall oder
praktikantin werkseitig let me islam
voll aber ich will teil von dem
staatlichen teil vertrag sprachlich
verlage gerichtsbarkeit sie genau um
dann hin wird die integration slider das
heißt sie im prinzip zurück schiebt aber
gleich wo sie genau die form folglich
berechtigung mit carla bruni kvb aber
mit
ausdruck für religiöse identität und den
damit in gruppen und stamm neutralität
ausspruch genau hinter das zurück was
sie eigentlich aus mir verständlich
grünen beanspruchen nämlich das aber im
prinzip gut mit sollte hintere ihre
freiheit der austreiben und weise
absolut die neutralität funktionierten
änderung ist vorgeschrieben und neue
qualität der priorität kazi das war dass
jede freiheit actros zuckerwasser sind
geplant ist eine höhere seite sind
papier staat und religionen kanton
zürich religiöse symbole dürfen im
öffentlichen raum sichtbar sein so weit
ist die staatlichen rechtsordnung zu
leisten und den staat religion hat eine
öffentliche rolle
sie ist keine reine privatsache aber
nicht öffentlichen raum und und
staatlicher als besonders schädlich also
ich will nicht dass wir das kruzifix ab
der kathedrale samuel oder wasser immer
in freiburg trat nennt das wetter das
architektonisch so es geht darum wie es
ein staatliche römerstadt oder das
wirklich einen unterschied also der
öffentliche raum im senf dass man das
macht strafbar und das feuer wurde das
kurze lied auftrag das ist dass ich für
mich wirklich ausdruck von der
individualität und als r8 von individuum
das er sonst trage
andere verstehen trikot als mine
religion oder verstehen gewisse andere
sache es ist ja interessant wenn wir das
problem sei dass einlädt person halt
grad muslimische symbole und das
christliche days in ordnung aber er hat
dort plötzlich hohen matti show wurde
bruder rufus oder che guevara oder so
und auch da ist das so der lifetime
lifestyle buddhismus oder lita der
anschläge war aufregend religiöse züge
also ich will einfach sagen chinesische
flugstatus tiefreligiöse ausdrücklich
oder natürlich gar nicht gemacht hat und
in den ferien gemacht hat also das kann
aber nicht alles in relevante pack oder
jugend ist ein kreativer als relevante
sind oder
das hat jetzt mit religion wenigsurfer
es geht so leider codes wird die
jugendlichen kennen die antwort und der
kostet natürlich auf das who die von der
firma verliert oder war zum beispiel
auch zeitdruck steht also auch adolf
hitler oder oder 88 8 also heil hitler
oder so aber die jugendlichen wo das
wild und diesen kreativ genug machen
richtig next zusätzliche symbole oder ja
nicht du bist ganz wichtig sei mir
scheint nicht dankeschön geht religiös
neutral das gibt's ja es gibt kein
einziger religiös neutralen jeder hat
wie sie halt ich zur religion dadurch
dass ein verständlicher form von
religion oder sie halt ich bin ich mich
zum göttlichen verhalten ebenfalls
verneint sie ist also dass es geht das
nicht und wird auch in den uniformen
aufzwingen hat jedes in die werthaltig
sind ihre haltung zur religion sind halt
ich zu einer höheren macht das ist
einfach da und das ist augenwischerei zu
meiner mit dem aktie von jacobs woche
von einer kippa sehr gut aus auf gewalt
ich finde der minimoys begangener
unterschiedlich unsere diskussion gern
prinzip reagieren sofort zu verrückt
aber was ich was ich los
gesellschaftlich was sagt das über das
aktuell läuft es ist ein kopf um
machtstrukturen kaum vom identität von
gemeinschaft klein und ich nimm show der
europäische gesellschaft in starker
identitätskampf wohl nicht nur religiös
abläufe sondern um religiöse symbol
abläufe im eine sehr problematische
kampf modell weiß autoritär ist durchweg
der und zum teil auf den sichtbar ist
ein quiz statt einander regierung
gewählt habe
und kritische ausdruck jetzt verdammt
was soll ich gesehen und ich war doch
mal sagen mein system ist nicht und
nicht von wechslern dass er krebs weil
meine amtsgebäude ausdruck vom staat ist
was das gebäude befindet
aber der mensch wo amtshandlung wohnen
im allgemeinen recht im prinzip sie sich
selber ausdruckt und nicht für das
start-stopp-system moment ich finde es
schade dass religion stande zankapfel
ist erstens religion also der wer wäre
nicht briefmarkensammeln hobby es ist
ein wald schauer oldiges rasiere mich
nie ein remake sondern als frieda und
dort ca
positiv wirke experte mancher als
vordruck zum anrufer als man mit respekt
begegnen aber die idee vor dem anstich
kritisiert und ich hoffe die idee eher
weniger speck noch kurz vorher was läuft
im moment also sehen zwar hat sie fühlt
sich beleidigt natur ihre intelligenz
fühlen sich beleidigt
genau solche leute oder wann etwas
gebraucht wird will und ich fühle mich
dann im inneren religion beleidigt wenn
es zum machtsymbol wird zum abgrund sich
zur ausgrenzung weil mit dem mit dem
trotzigen überlegenheit muss
demonstriert werden an politik
populismus gemacht hat ist dass
missbrauch von roth da fühle ich mich im
inneren religion für dich stand sein
dass sie über migräne den diskussionen
und charmante sie ein zur betont in
kurzer und verehrt und werthaltig ganz
herzlicher dank für das gespräch für die
diskussion
nächste woche können sie den blick über
in religiöser alltag von menschen in der
schweiz wo zum hinduismus gehört mit
zeigen ihnen sogenannte pusher 4 in der
hindu tempel im turban und jetzt wartet
sie auf goldstar der stamm sprung
philosophie um phänomen wir
gedankenübertragung spuk und geistern
ihnen ein schönes und decken
[Musik]